I like eating out.
I would say I probably eat out about three times a week.
My favorite is Japanese food.
I like almost everything they serve:...
...the sushi, the noodles, and the fried vegetables.
They also have full - course authentic Japanese meals,...
...but I rarely get them because they're expensive and it's too much food.
Without a doubt, I prefer eating out to cooking because I live by myself.
I cook when I have company over,...
...but otherwise, I am more likely to go out with friends for dinner.
I find cooking only for myself depressing.
It is also a waste of time and it also costs less for me to eat out than to go grocery shopping.
I live in a neighborhood where there are a lot of ethnic food restaurants.
I like trying out different kinds of food.
Luckily, I have a friend who enjoys the same thing.
Tonight, we're going to a new Indian restaurant to try their curry.
I can't wait!
I hope it tastes good.